awareness
is god
think about it like the pupil
the pupil is what is shared
among us
that is eternal
experiencing these dreamed
creation designs
and when you get to the understanding
in this analogy that the pupil
is god the pupil the awareness the
consciousness the observer the witness
the i am is
what is eternal and it shared
the pupil
that's a huge step
towards god realization
now to merge that
wisdom with the wisdom
of the uniqueness the artistic
individuation
of the iris
that's each of our unique colorations
that unique artistry
is an expression of the infinite
we are eternally taking on these unique
artistic expressions which you can see
clearly in all of our unique
irises
the iris is our unique artistic
individuation our expression
this is very much deeply and profoundly
like a synthesis
of the perennial wisdom of the spiritual
mystic traditions
especially of the east
the non-dual awareness of the pupil
with the unique enlightenment
individuation
realizations of the unique artistry
of the west of modernity
hold the synthesis the simultaneity of
the non-duality
with the unique individuation
you are the pupil that is eternal that
is
shared among us the god the observer the
witness
while you are also the unique artistic
expression individuation of the iris
that is your creative gift that you are
actualizing into this dreamed creation
design
and it is all infinity expressing itself
recognize this and you got it
recognize this and it brings
an expansive release
of a contracted egoic finite
biological energy to a
expanded release
of infinitude expressing itself
you recognize the god realization of the
pupil
and you recognize the god actualization
of the iris
and you're able to simultaneity
navigate that like a jedi
with deep wisdom and grace
fluidly
you're able to have dialectic
at the level of eternity of infinity
of god realization of being a mirror and
providing really good questions for
other people
to help them recognize that infinitude
while also on the god actualization on
the infinite
actualization on the iris
side you are able to help with the
optimization especially
entrepreneurially
do people know how to have a high
digital quotient do they know how to
disseminate their
artistic ideas memetically across the
information technology age
do they know how to optimize on an
emotional intelligence level
how to ask really good questions to get
shatter the surface level conversations
and get to the depths of the psyche
can you optimize like a jedi on both of
those angles on the god
realization angle i'm the shared eternal
observer witness
infinitely expressing itself as these
irises as these unique artistic
expressions and
optimize the efficacy of the
entrepreneurial creative spirit outward
the yin and yang of the inward with the
outward the
inward with the outward the inward
with the outward become aware of
awareness eternal and shared
and become aware of the optimization of
the artistic expression
outward boom
that's the direct path to peace
and to happiness to recognition of our
infinitude
expressing itself in these creation
designs
we are all already in union
with infinity
that's why it's so frequently talked
about
like there is no path it's a pathless
path it's a veilless veil
it's a gateless gate
it's a flat mountain
how do i find the diamond necklace that
is already around my neck
you're already it but the mind is so
noisy that it prevents the insight
two thousand years ago patanjali
that yoga or union with the absolute
with god
is simply the quieting
of the waves of consciousness
quiet the waves of consciousness
we are so immersed in the clouds
of thoughts and feelings and emotions
and beliefs and perceptions and
sensations
objects seeking happiness and peace
externally that we forget
that the sky the awareness
is eternal it's shared
and we take that macro level observer
view
of the clouds as the sky
that's the winning formula
that's the infinite recognizing its own
true nature
and then it has the blissful peaceful
experience
of the clouds because it knows its own
true nature
while that's happening and it's able to
share that peace and happiness
like the tantric path like ramana
maharshi said was sahaja samadhi you
weave your profound realizations into
the social fabric in the dreamed
creation design
if there is a struggle with
quieting the mind there are so
many great ways to assist with that
process
the quieting of the mind can be most
simply
conquered through respiration
you already have the best tool with you
all the time
free of cost it's called prana for a
reason it's the life force the life
energy itself is right here in the yin
and yang of the breath
of the inhalation and the exhalation
because the monkey mind tries and
wanders all the time to all of the
different
clouds but what happens is
when we focus on the breath and we
attentively bring our attention
over and over and over again to the
breath
over time the monkey mind those
roots of the monkey mind that spring and
wander to the clouds they
calm down they calm down and what opens
up
is the observer the sky the witness
becoming aware of awareness and that's
the game
is to hone in on respiration hone
in on quieting the monkey mind and
allowing the eternal the infinite
observer that is shared
among us to open up recognize yourself
as that sky and that's
it
you are that
i and my father are one we
are it the diamond necklace around each
of our necks
refracting the source light uniquely
because
each gem in jewel is its own
unique creative expression artistically
outward
that gem slash jewel slash diamond can
be dirty when we don't
understand our own true nature
and we go outward as the contracted
energy of the finite separate ego
and the turn inward like the parable of
the prodigal son
is the cleansing the purifying of the
diamond
of the jewel of the mirror so that it
refracts
with purity that source light
as the absolute highest morality
going outward in that tantric path
of maximizing human potential weaving
enlightened realizations into the social
fabric
ask yourself how do i
find the diamond necklace that is
already around my neck
you are already it you are complete
already as that eternal
infinite you are complete already
the expression of it artistically
outward is a constant beautiful
dreamed creative process
every moment of that process you are
complete
and it's a beautiful process itself
of the creative expression outward as
well
of the turn inward of piercing the
veilless veil of
recognizing as the sufi metaphysic
wadat al-wujud means the unity of all
finding all of the unique ways of the
turn
inward and all of the different
conceptual schemas of
understanding the infinite the eternal
god
awareness and that piercing the veilus
veil and finding
that's the beauty of infinity expressing
itself
we are always already complete
and we are always already
in a beautiful artistic expressionary
process
in a process of turning inward
purifying our mirror our gem recognizing
our own true nature
finding the infinitude that we are
and optimizing the efficacy that
we artistically express ourselves
outward with
the jigsaw piece that always
fits each of us
each expression of infinity
is the jigsaw piece that always
perfectly fits
you are what you want
as saint francis of assisi said
that which you seek is what is seeking
the seer itself is what you are seeking
that's why you won't find the peace and
the happiness in objects and conspicuous
consumption
in greed and clout and fame you will
only find the peace and happiness
by recognizing your own true infinite
eternal
shared nature of the seer of the witness
of the observer becoming aware of
awareness itself
and with that knowledge
veda gnosis
when you have this nanya when you have
that going outward is flawless
morally ethically maximizing prosperity
there's no lack
you are what you want
all desire is for recognition of
infinity
all desire
in whatever the external substances
relationships peak experiences
all of that externalization of happiness
and peace externally
is all the desire to feel even if it's
for
just a minute or two minutes or ten
minutes
in a day to feel infinity
to feel our true nature as bliss and
peace
and each of us deserves to feel our true
nature as bliss and peace
24 hours a day seven days a week
not 10 minutes per day
and that's the recognition of our true
nature
that's when we realize our infinitude
that's when we recognize that's what
we've been desiring
all the time is that infinite well
of honey that is just
located underneath of the rock
of the contracted separate finite egoic
entity as sri aurobindo said
and as rupert spira says
we dissolve the contracted
egoic finite entity like a
sugar cube in the hot tea
of infinity
and that's when we recognize the eternal
well of that peace of that happiness
which we then weave into
the social fabric
the seer is eternal
it's shared it is god it is the pupil
and the unique artistic expression
is the iris
imagine the whole color palette that's
available
all of the different combinations of
mixes
that are possible for each iris it's
infinite
there are eight billion right now
and there have been a hundred billion
that have lived and died before these
eight billion
right now only
a hundred and eight billion combinations
way more than that infinity
before that infinity after that
we will never finish exploring
something that is unbounded
it's impossible to come to the end of
all of the creative combinations
of infinity expressing itself
this is but one of the expressions
of infinity this dreamed creation design
of this planet with these people
with this unique civilizational story
is but one expression of infinity
and when you recognize your eternity
when you recognize your infinitude
that has been undergoing this process of
creatively expressing itself with all of
these different unique irises
across all of these different unique
creation designs
in all of these dreams just like you do
when you go to sleep
at night and you dream your own
simulated reality
where you immerse yourself into the
first person perspective and embark on a
unique
journey that that is exactly what this
is when that dream ends
and it goes whoop the next dream
simulation starts
has the observer changed has the process
of observing of witnessing that dream
simulated environment changed
no that is the eternal
awareness that is
constantly being colored by the
different experiences of the dream
simulated realities
even quantum mechanically the profound
revelation
in the just last hundred years all is
no thing all is energy all
is the infinite modulations the infinite
expressions the infinite fluctuations
of the underlying energy that then
create the
appearance of form
of matter
symphonically how many different
songs can musically be played
infinite endless an unbounded amount
this is but one of the songs that our
symphony plays
symphonies don't play just one song
this is the eternal symphony
and we are unique creative
artists in that symphony with all of our
unique
colorations of our iris where we are
playing
different instruments different melodies
and those that have the recognition of
the infiniti they play in tune
and those that don't have the
recognition that are coming from the
contracted finite egoic separate entity
they are playing out of tune and they
are hitting
the breaking point of that egoic
contraction
and then like in the parable of the
prodigal son turning inward
recognizing their infinitude and then
playing
in tune outward
the i without coloration of identity
is shared the i
with coloration of identity is unique
art
as we frequently use in our analogies
again massively influenced by rupert
spyra
the i without the coloration of identity
is shared
you can tell
it is the same pure bare empty awareness
without the coloration of identity
that's what we share that's the pupil
and this is the iris with the coloration
of identity as unique
art look this pure bear empty awareness
is being uniquely colored by
words and this pure bear empty awareness
is being uniquely colored by
art
and just like that each of us has this
unique iris
coloration and yet we all share
the pupil the eternal
awareness that is infinitely being
colored
by all of these unique experiences in
these dreamed
creation designs
the key is to bring your peace and
happiness
to society once you god realize
once you recognize that you are infinity
expressing itself
you bring the peace and happiness to
society
you no longer try to extract
peace and happiness from society
you're not seeking a substance or a
relationship or an experience to extract
peace and happiness from it but you are
bringing your eternal well
of honey of peace and happiness
and awe in love and light
and wisdom and grace to every single
cloud of experience
with your family with your friends with
your co-workers with people online with
the community with the world
you are bringing peace and happiness
and that's how you vortex people
people become gravitated to
the peace and happiness that you are
bringing
and they wonder why don't i have 24
7 peace and happiness why do i only have
10 minutes
of peace and happiness per day
and that's the turn inward that's when
you become the vortex
helping people turn inward acting as
that pure
clean mirror helping them with
atmavichara self-inquiry into the
question
what is i
is that i shared and eternal
and am i a creative expression of that
infinitude
and you vortex people in they make the
realization and boom
outward sahaja samadhi the natural
weaving of the highest morality into the
social fabric
this is enlightenment simply recognition
of our true nature
the seeker prepares to know
themselves as intelligent infinity
and it blends the micro
of that unique individuation with the
macro
of the intelligent infinity expressing
itself
as the micro of the unique
artistic expression
and upon that recognition
that unique expression becomes a very
clear pure vessel
for the one to express itself
harmonically
in deep alignment with
the enlightened realization of
infinity eternally
expressing itself creatively
simple as that
awareness is god shared
eternal the pupil
the iris is the unique artistic
expression infinity
eternally expressing itself
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure
cause of delight
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure
cause of delight
it's that simple
and we bring the peace and happiness
to
the dreamed creation design
rather than trying to extract it from it
calm your mind with the tool that's
always with you the breath
will bring the fluctuations of the mind
over time
down to the quietude that is needed to
recognize the diamond necklace of
awareness that is already
here the perfect
jigsaw puzzle piece that always
fits
adore you thank you
if the video brought you value give it a
like if you haven't yet subscribe
leave a comment below would love to hear
from you
share the video with people that you
feel this would make a profound
impact on
let's spread the simplicity of the
child-like
analogies
like the pupil and the iris so simple
thank you infinite love
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure
cause of delight
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure cause of
delight
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure cause of the
light
hehe